everybody who supported this song who  watched the video I love you so much but  what about love for Taylor Swift  Calvin Harris won the MTV VMA for Best  Male video for this is what you came for  a song that features Rihanna and was  secretly co-written by his acts Taylor  but the DJ producer avoided mentioning  Tay in his speech which was three taped  because he couldn't be there I have a  show tonight in the UK getting props  though the videos director Emil Nava and  of course Rihanna  you bring something so magical to the  projects thank you et was inside the  VMAs after Calvin's wayna boos were  heard from the crowd but it wasn't clear  if it was because he skipped the show or  didn't give Taylor a shout-out